シャッシャッシャッ（カードを切る音）
はじめ）このウェイストブルー20万するらしいよ･･･
まさき）20万？！
は）ふっ･･･
は）こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと
ま）まっ
は）我々、遊戯王にはまっているわけなんですけども
は）遊戯王ってどういうゲームかというと
は）相手のライフポイントを8000ポイント削ったら勝ちというゲームでございます
は）他にもいろんな勝ち方があるんですけども
は）基本的には8000ポイントのライフポイントを攻撃して
は）0にしたら勝ちなんですけど
ま）ふっふっふ・・・ｗｗｗ
は）気になんない？でも
は）いつも8000でやってるのを100万でやんだよ？
は）どんな世界が待ってんの俺たちにｗ
ま）確実にワンキルが無い
は）ワンキル無いね、一発で殺すのはほぼ無理ですね･･･
は）なんで今回ちょっとこの２人で
は）1回ライフポイント100万で遊戯王やってみようと思います
は）特別ルールとしてですね、
は）遊戯王デッキが0枚になると負けなんですけども、
は)ライフポイント100万でやると
は）デッキが0枚になるのが当たり前なんで
は）デッキが0枚になったら、墓地のカードをデッキに戻して
は）もう1回やることにします
は）すいません、これは特別ルールで
は）ひとまず100万のライフを0になる瞬間までやって
は）どれだけ（時間が）かかるかという
は）基本的に特殊勝利がないという戦いで1回
は）遊戯王やってみようと思います
は）ではいこうっ！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！
バァァァァァァァァァァン
は）よろしくお願いします
ま）お願いしまーす
は）ちなみにまさきのデッキは
は）クリフォートって言って
は）すごい攻撃力が高い機械族モンスターで
は）殴り倒すデッキです
は）僕は、
は）ダ・イーザデッキって言って、
は）お互い結構すごい攻撃力高いので殴り合うから
は）いけるんじゃないかな割と早い時間で
は）100万だよ？え、ほんとに100万だよね？
は）いち、じゅう、ひゃく、せん、まん
は）じゅうまん、ひゃくまん、おっけおっけ
は）大丈夫だよね？
は）もう1回確認しといてよ
は）人生に関わってるからｗ
デュエルっ！！！！！！！！！
は）最初はグー、じゃんけんぽんっ！
ま）先行！　は）はいどうぞ
は）早くっ、早くっ
デュエル中・・・
は）まさきくんのライフポイントが
は）99万9200になりましたｗ
デュエル中・・・
は）まさきのライフポイントあと
は）99万5000です　ま）ふふふｗ
デュエル中・・・
は）で、神宣でまさきのライフポイントが半分になります
は）割る2だよね？
ま）割る2
は）でかいよ！これ！
は）いくよ？　　ま）うん
うおぉぉぉぉぉぉぉおお！きたーーーー！
は）48万まできたぞ！
デュエル中・・・
は）待ってました神宣！！
ま）うわぁぁぁぁぁあ
は）これおいらがまた半分になるんだよね？
は）割る2だよね？　　ま）うん
は）でかいでかい
は）うおぉぉぉぉぉ39万！！
は）早いぞこれ結構
デュエル中・・・
は）ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
は）逆転したぞぉぉぉ～！！
デュエル中・・・
は）神宣！
は）いくぜっ！
は）うわぁ、わっ・・・
は）15万まできた、15万まできた（小声）
デュエル中・・・
ま）ふっふっふｗｗｗ
は）6875だよｗ
デュエル中・・・
は）うおぉぉぉここでか！
ま）やる気あんの？ｗｗ
は）やめてよ！早くっ！ｗ
デュエル中・・・
は）受けましょう！
ま）はははｗｗ
は）ちょっと待って早く早く･･･
は）はい！
は）終了ぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉおお！！！（拍手）
は）そこっそこ長いね
は）もうちょっとなんか
は）2時間とかかかるかと思ったんですけど
は）まあお互い打点が高いデッキの、などと･･･
は）常にロックされて何もできなかったから
は）かなり、いいタイムだと思います、これは
は）えっとまあライフポイント100万でやったところ
は）で、ライフポイントが
は）僕が0でまさきの残りが10万9962.5
は）神の宣告を使って割る2が何回か起きたので
は）小数点がついてしまいました
♪エンディング♪